SRINI DEVADAS: So
today, we're going
to look at that classic puzzle.
It's called the
eight queens puzzle,
and it's very easy to describe.
I'll write down the rules, if
you happen not to know chess
and how a queen moves on a
chess board, in a moment.
But before I get
into that, I just
wanted to mention that
the programming paradigms
that we're going to be
looking at today are--
is, I should say the
programming paradigm--
is one of exhaustive
enumeration.
And what we want to
do algorithmically
is to look at all
possible cases,
all possible combinations,
possibilities,
because we want to
exhaust the space
to determine if
there's a solution
to this particular instance
of the problem or not.
And one of the problems,
as I mentioned,
is the eight queen's problem.
But you could say, I'd
like to solve a smaller
problem, the five queens problem
or the three queens problem.
And you'd like, obviously,
to be able to write code that
solves this generalized
problem, where
you can vary the number of
rows and columns on a board.
It's no longer a chessboard if
it's not eight rows and eight
columns, but you can
still obviously concoct
a puzzle associated with
an arbitrary-sized board.
And then the other
thing that we'll do
today is look at
data structures,
and so this obviously is going
to be a data structure that's
immediately clear
from what I have
up there on the board,
a matrix data structure
to solve the problem.
But can you do things
more efficiently
with a different selection
of a data structure?
All right?
So the eight queens
problem simply
says, place eight
queens on a chessboard--
and that implies immediately
that it's eight by eight,
as I've drawn over there--
such that no queen
attacks any other queen.
Now, if you had no background
in solving this problem,
perhaps you knew chess, and you
might think there's a solution.
You might think there's not.
I mean, a queen is
pretty powerful.
This implies, because a
queen can move horizontally.
It can move vertically.
It can move diagonally, back
and forth, in both directions,
up and down, left and right, and
I guess up and down diagonally.
It's a powerful piece.
It's the most powerful
piece in chess.
And first time I heard
about this problem,
my guess was that there wasn't
a solution to the eight queens
problem.
And you know, how many
of you think there's
a solution to this problem?
Do you know there's
a solution, or do you
think there's a solution?
AUDIENCE: For sure,
because knights,
because they can't
move like in the way
a knight can, so
it's got to be--
SRINI DEVADAS: So Ganatra
says there's a solution.
How many of you,
before you heard him,
thought there wasn't a solution?
Well, you know, years
ago, I was convinced
that there was no solution,
because I tried very hard
and I couldn't find one.
I tried very hard
for a half hour, OK?
And then I decided
there wasn't one.
But then, you know, now at
this point, it got to the point
where I could write a computer
program in about a half hour
or an hour to
solve this problem,
and I did discover a solution.
So I'm giving it away.
It turns out there's
many solutions,
and there's certainly a
slightly different code
for finding one solution
versus finding all of them,
and we'll do both.
So without further ado,
you want to translate
the movement of the
queens into a set of rules
that tell you if you have
found a solution or not.
And there's essentially
three rules,
because a queen can move
in three different ways.
No two queens can be
on the same column.
No two queens can
be in the same row.
No two queens can be
in the same diagonal.
And remember, there's two
diagonals, one of which
that goes this way, and the
other one that goes that way.
Right, so there's a lot
of combinations here.
If you think about this and you
look at this board over here,
I have eight different rows
and eight different columns.
And the way that someone might
try to solve this problem
is go either left or
right or top down.
And I've written the
constraint no two queens can
be in the same column first.
So you can imagine, then, this
is what we're going to do.
You could certainly modify the
code and modify our strategy,
but we're going to
go left to right.
So what we're going to do is, we
know if we put a queen up here,
we can't put a queen in any
other row on that first column,
obviously, because of
the first constraint.
So maybe I'll put
a queen up here.
And then at that point, I
can move to the second column
in my manual strategy.
And I couldn't put
a queen up here
because of the
second constraint,
no two queens can
be on the same row.
And if I had a queen up here--
let me just write that out.
So I can't put one here,
I can't put one here.
I could put one
here, and this goes
back to what Ganatra
said, about this
is how a knight moves in chess.
And so that gets me two queens.
And obviously, not a solution
to the problem of the eight
queens, but maybe I'm a quarter
of the way there, right?
And it turns out
that you have to do
what is called backtracking.
And backtracking
simply means you
may have to undo a
decision you made
with respect to the placement
of a particular queen
in this exhaustive
search strategy, right?
And the important
thing when you do
a search, as I
mentioned early on,
you have to convince yourself
that the code you've written
is going to exhaust all
of the possibilities,
and that it won't
miss solutions.
And if you don't exhaust
all the possibilities,
your code will
terminate, and you
may throw up your hands,
because you had buggy code,
or because you had a
buggy search strategy,
and say, there's no
solution to the problem,
whereas there is a
solution to the problem.
All right?
And the way you do this search,
this exhaustive search--
because it's quite intense,
there's a lot of combinations,
and they grow exponentially with
the number of rows and columns
on our board--
is important.
And so you want to
be careful that you
don't do redundant work,
that you don't do things
that you don't really have to,
because the combinations blow
up.
So there's hundreds of millions
of combinations with respect
to putting queens up here, so
if you really think about it,
there's like eight
different places
you can put a queen here,
eight, eight, eight et cetera.
So you know, that's
8 raised to 8 right?
If you think about that.
And that's a large
number, right?
And if you translate that, I
don't even know what that is.
But you could do--
you know, this is 2
raised to 3, raised to 8,
so that's 2 raised to 24,
which is in the millions.
And if you had larger board--
it isn't a chessboard-- then
it would be much, much larger
as you grew the
size of the board.
But that 2 raised to 24
doesn't scare us these days,
because computers are so fast.
But back when I was your age,
that was a large number, OK?
And you didn't
want to write code
that took 2 raised to 24
steps to solve problems.
Now it takes a matter
of fractions of seconds
to run through those
kinds of combinations,
because you're running at
a gigahertz on computers.
But before we dive
into the specifics
of a particular strategy,
let's look at smaller problems.
You always get
intuition about problems
by shrinking them and
making them simpler.
So let's look at the case
of a two-by-two board.
Can I solve the two queens
problem on a two-by-two board?
No.
So if I put a queen here,
well, immediately I cannot put
a queen--
it attacks all of
these other positions.
So the two-by-two does
not have a solution.
Let's look at a three-by-three.
Right.
So let's say I put
a queen up here.
So the way I'm doing this, by
the way, is column by column,
and that's kind of going
to be our strategy.
As I said, you could
flip it to row by row,
but no reason to do both.
Just pick one.
And so I put a queen up here.
I can't put one here,
I can't put one here, right?
So I go ahead and
put that over here.
Can I put a queen here?
No, because that attacks it.
No, because this attacks it.
And clearly, I can't
do it over here.
So am I done?
Can I just give up now?
What should I do?
I don't want to give up now.
I don't want to say that a
three-by-three-- at this point,
I don't know what the
answer is in terms
of whether a solution exists
for a three-by-three or not.
But at this point, given
that I put a queen up here,
and I went through this process,
I cannot give up, right?
And why cannot I give up?
What should I do next,
once I've failed here?
I put a queen here and a queen
here, and I said, um, you know,
I can't put a queen
anywhere here.
What do I do?
Right?
Yeah, go ahead, Fadi.
AUDIENCE: You can change the
position of the first queen.
SRINI DEVADAS: You can
change the position
of the first queen.
That's exactly right.
So I need to backtrack, and so
I tried a few different things
here.
And it was exactly
the same thing,
where I had a queen here.
And let's say I have a very
straightforward strategy that
is going to put queens down
and run a piece of code that is
going to check for conflicts.
This is going to be our most
important subroutine that we're
going to write, and it's going
to be dependent on the data
structure that we picked, but
that is our fundamental check,
you know, the conflict checker.
So I could put a queen here.
And obviously, with
one queen, there's
no reason to run the
conflict checker.
When I put a queen here, I
run the conflict checker,
and it says, conflict.
Here, conflict.
Here, no conflict.
Right?
And then I move on to the
next, and I get conflict
for all three of them, right?
So at this point, I have
to have a way in my code--
this is exactly the enumeration
that I need in my code,
to go back and say, just like
I tried different combinations
for the second column
before I converged
on putting a queen
down here, I need
to go back and change
this to do this.
So I put a queen here, then
can I put a queen here?
Here?
No, right?
So that doesn't work either.
So then I go up and
put a queen here,
and now you know where this is
headed, because of symmetry.
The only place I can put
a queen is over here.
And once I put the
queen over there,
I can't put a queen
in any of these spots.
So it turns out a three-by-three
does not have a solution.
At this point, because I've gone
through all of the combinations
with respect to the starting
points on the first column,
and then with each of
those starting points,
I've gone through all
of the combinations
in the second column
and the third column,
I've effectively
done the 3 raised
to 3, which was basically what
I described to you previously
with respect to these
different combinations.
Now I don't know if the 8--
we kind of think at
this point that there
is a solution in those 8 raised
to 8 combinations for the eight
queens problem.
But there was no
solution in the 2 raised
to 2 combinations for
the two queens problem.
And there were no
solutions in the 3 raised
to 3 combinations or placements
for the three queens problem.
OK?
So let's do four queens.
And the reason I'm
doing this is I
want to point out one thing,
which is an efficiency
trick that is going to
be important to make sure
that our code runs in a
reasonable amount of time.
Right?
And which is kind of implicit
in what we've done here,
but I want to point it out.
So in the case of four
queens, I'm going to go off
and I'm going to
put a queen up here.
And I'm going to run
through this fairly quickly.
No, no, yes.
And so I move on.
No, no, no, no, no.
Right?
So oops-- but now, I
don't need to go back
all the way to the first.
I can put a queen here, right?
So now, no, yes, so I
get a little further.
And then I could move
to the fourth column.
No, no, no, no.
I mean, they attacked from
here or attack from there.
Oops, all right.
Let's just go-- can
I put it over here?
No, no.
I went back to the most
recently placed queen, OK?
So one thing that is important,
which you kind of get a sense
for when you increase
the size of the board,
is when you fail, when check
conflicts returns false,
when you fail, you go back to
the most recent decision, most
recent column that
you've placed your queen,
and you change that, and you
enumerate those possibilities.
OK?
And when you do that--
the other thing that
we've done, by the way,
is for the first queen, we put
a queen down with impunity.
For the second queen, we check
that lone, existing queen
on the board for
a conflict, right?
For the third queen, what am I
doing here for the third queen?
What conflicts am
I checking when
I place the third queen
on one of the rows
of the third column,
specifically?
What conflicts am I checking?
I mean, who am I checking with?
Yeah, go ahead back there.
AUDIENCE: The two
queens that you--
SRINI DEVADAS: Yeah,
the two queens.
And what am I doing
for the existing queens
that are already on the board?
Do I do anything for them?
No.
So I guess it doesn't
seem like much,
but it's an important notion.
OK?
The notion here is I'm
doing a certain amount
of incremental checking
when I place a new queen,
and it's only the new
relationships that
the new queen--
or the conflicts that the
new queen would have that
need to be checked.
And in general, you know,
if I had seven queens up
on the board, and
I've set it up nicely
with these seven queens--
they're all happy, right?
They're non-conflicting.
No reason to go look at each
of those pairs of seven queens
when I put an eighth queen
down, as I change the position
of the eighth queen.
All I care about is that the
eighth queen doesn't conflict
with the first seven queens.
So I have to check, in general,
if I'm putting the k-th queen
down, and I'm
effectively checking
for k minus 1 pairs of
conflicts, or k minus 1 queens
were already put down.
The k-th queen is
being put down,
and I need to check for the
ones that already existed.
I don't have to do k
minus 1 squared, right?
You know, because the k
minus 1 were in there.
There's different
pairs over there.
I'm all done with
that, all right?
I'm all done with that.
All right, so let's
keep going here.
So where was I?
I forget exactly
where I was at, but we
decided that this
didn't work, because I
failed on column four.
But I can put it over here, and
I can put it over here, right?
So now, at this point, I've
gone through and I've said,
look, what it means now is
that for these two positions
for the first two
columns, there's
no solution to the
four queens problem.
OK?
And so I exhausted the
positions, for this position.
I've also exhausted-- so I can
say something even stronger
than that, because
for this position,
I looked at the two
possibilities, which
were this and that, and neither
of them work as well, right?
So the stronger statement
now is that there's
no solution to the
four queens problem
if you put a queen on the
top-left corner, right?
But it doesn't mean that there's
no solution to the four queens
problem.
Ganatra you had a question.
AUDIENCE: Can't you
also say there's
no solution when you put
the queen on the bottom one?
SRINI DEVADAS: Symmetry,
yes, wonderful.
So it turns out that you can
do rotations and reflections,
and if you are willing
to take your code.
Remember that
computers are dumb.
You have to explain to
them what a rotation is
and what a reflection is.
But if you do that,
then it turns out
you can get significant
reductions in 8 raised to 8,
or what have you.
Right?
And I'll go back
and I'll tell you
about the number of solutions
to the eight queens problem,
if you just looked
at it this way,
without rotating
yourself or reflecting,
and then tell you how many
unique solutions there actually
are, if you took into account
the symmetries associated
with rotation and reflection.
And the last part is important,
because it can cut down
your combinatorial search, if
you do take that into account,
right?
But as I said, you know, for
our purposes, 2 raised to 24
is not a large number
anymore, so we can just
blast through and
not have to do that.
All right?
But now what I need to do
is I've erased everything.
You know, I tried that
first queen in the corner.
It's probably not going
to work here, right?
And so because of--
well, no probably.
It will not work here.
Sorry about that.
But you know, this
is different, right?
I mean, that clearly we
have to check, right?
So here, no.
Here, no.
Yes.
Right?
And then here, yes, right?
So I could put that over here.
And then I move on.
Here, no.
Here, yes.
That's right.
So we don't know if there's
not another solution.
And in fact, there is.
There's two solutions.
We won't go there, but 4 by 4--
I'm sorry, four
queens has a solution.
OK?
So now we're ready to code, OK?
Now we're ready to code.
The one thing we need to do
is decide on a data structure.
But before I show you
the code, or even talk
about the data
structure, I do want
you to keep in mind this search
strategy that we employed,
right?
And the search strategy was
a column-by-column search
strategy, and it requires
enumeration and changing
positions of queens.
And deciding when
to do that is going
to be based on whether check
conflicts gives you back
true or false.
And we can set up
check conflicts,
so it's not checking--
there's two ways
you could do this.
You could say, here's a board.
I'm going to check all pairs
of conflicts associated
with all the queens
on the board,
and I'm going to just use
that procedure over and over.
That's not what we did
in our search strategy.
What we did was we have a check
conflict strategy that really
takes a new queen as an
argument and the existing board
as the second argument, right?
And it's really checking for
the new queen's conflicts
with the existing queens,
and that cuts down
on the amount of computation
that you want to do.
All right?
So given that, what is the most
natural data structure that you
can think of that would be
applicable to the eight queens
problem or the four
queens problem?
What's the most
natural data structure
that you can think of?
Someone?
Yeah, go ahead, Ryan.
AUDIENCE: Two-dimensional array.
SRINI DEVADAS:
Two-dimensional array.
Two-dimensional list,
and that's exactly right.
So let's say that I decided to
do exactly what Ryan suggested,
and what I'm going
to do is, I'm going
to have a two-dimensional
array, or two-dimensional list.
In Python, you know,
we call them lists,
which looks like this.
And this is going to look
exactly like the board
that you have there.
Two-dimensional.
This is the list of lists,
and you have lists in here.
And so the important
thing, people--
all of you, if you
haven't already,
will spend some debugging time
in your programming careers,
figuring out why
things don't work,
to try and figure out
why things don't work.
And it'll be because
you flipped the I and J
indices of a two-dimensional
array, or a list, OK?
Because you'll think that some
things are rows and some things
are columns, and you'll
flip them around.
So I don't want to do that.
I already did that
enough times in my life,
so I don't want to do that.
And so right here, I think
of B0 as the first row.
Right?
So this thing here is B0.
So when I say
something like B 2, 3,
what is the value of
B 2, 3 in my list B?
1.
All right?
And B 3, 2 is 0,
OK?
So that's-- I mean, I could
obviously have confused myself.
There'd be a bug
in the code if I'd
switched the identities of
rows and columns, right?
That's exactly the point.
So I can now imagine that
check conflicts, given
what we said about
incremental checking--
but it still has
to do, obviously,
computation on the B array,
or look at the B array,
and decide what's going on.
I'm going to be putting in 1s
and 0s inside of the B array.
And the first two--
I mean, they're all
straightforward.
I mean, it's not
complicated code here.
But the first two checks
are slightly easier
than the third check.
No two Queens on the
same column implies
that I need to actually look
at the first index changing,
you know, from 0 to 3.
And for some particular--
I could just write
this out here.
So no two Queens
on the same coin
them would mean that I
want to go 0 through--
let's just call it--
7, because I have
the 8 Queens problem.
And then I need to look
at i where i varies--
actually, let me
just call that j.
I like i for rows
and j for columns.
And j varies-- j would be 0.
And then you check that B 0,
7, 0 only has one 1, all right?
That's essentially what
I need to check for.
And then I need to
check it for j equals 0.
I need to check
it for j equals 1.
I need to check it for j
equals 2, et cetera, right?
That make sense?
And then, no two
Queens on the same row,
I need to check that B i
and i can go from 0 to 7.
I'm sorry, no two Queens
can be on the same row.
Yeah, that's right.
So this goes from 0 to 7.
And then I fix the
value of the column.
This is fixed.
So right now, let's just say
that I look at the first row.
I'd go 0 here.
And then I go 0 through 7 here.
And then I make sure that, on
B 0, there's exactly one 1,
right?
All right.
So we're good here?
Yeah?
OK.
The diagonal is the i and
j both change, all right?
And the thing with
the diagonal is--
and I'll show you
the code for this.
I think it's much easier to
explain the code as opposed
to drawing things now.
Because it's about the
specifics of things.
And so here it is.
So what I have here is--
I call it noConflicts().
noConflicts() has the board,
which is our B array here,
or B list.
In general, we're going to
be working incrementally
on the current column.
So that's what that is.
So you move from 0
to all the way down.
And then you have
something that we're
going to call qindex,
which is where you are.
So you have two things that
you need to worry about.
You're working on a
column that's current.
And then you also
have the position
that corresponds
to the row where
you're putting the Queen down.
So you obviously need
two of these values for--
to point into the
2-dimensional list.
So that's your qindex over here.
And this simply is
setting n to be 4.
I mean, I could--
this is a general procedure.
But because I'm calling this
in a 4-Queens procedure,
we're going to do
iteratively now.
So I need to know exactly how
many rows and columns they
are on my board.
So I've just set that
up to be n equals 4.
But that's essentially
that dimension.
So as you can,
I'm going to check
that there's a single 1
in the current column.
This is what I was trying
to go over over there.
But I think this code is
probably more evocative.
I'm simply checking to
see that the number of 1s
in the current column
is not greater than 1.
If it is greater than 1, then,
immediately, I'd return False.
And then here, this is
a little bit easier.
I check that the current Queen--
this is-- the row on which
the current Queen is on only
has one Queen on it.
And for the--
remember, as I'm going,
there's a single 1 in
the current column.
And this thing here
says I need to check
that, when I put a Queen
down here, that this is the--
I need to check this entire row
to make sure that this Queen is
the only one on it, all right?
And then I also need to
check this and that, OK?
And so those two checks are
over here, this and that.
So the diagonal,
the left diagonal,
is the first one,
the first check.
And then the one that
goes over to the right
is the second check, all right?
And again-- yeah,
go ahead, Fadi.
AUDIENCE: In the
first procedure,
like, when we were checking
for that only one Queen
was in one column-- so
I see in my mind that
is qindex equal to i.
Why is that line added?
Like here, we're
checking that if we
add the Queen in that position,
that there's no conflict.
SRINI DEVADAS: Are you
talking about this line here?
AUDIENCE: Yes, exactly.
And also, because our algorithm
makes sure that as we progress,
we add, at each stack,
one Queen per column,
why do we have, in
the first place,
to check for column conflict?
SRINI DEVADAS: Beautiful.
That's a great question.
So I'm going to answer that
in a minute or so, all right?
So Fadi was asking about
whether the checks are redundant
or not.
And he was pointing to a
particular piece of code.
Let me explain this code.
And then I'll answer
Fadi's question, OK?
So what I have here is our--
this is actually the search
algorithm, all right?
And this is exactly
what we've talked
about up until this point.
You're going to go over--
you're going to go
column by column, right?
And then you're going
to go row by row.
And so that's essentially
what the two loops are.
There's lots of loops
here, obviously, right?
You know, this is
horrible code, right?
I mean, I'm not saying
this is pretty code, right?
But this is horrible code.
And what happens here
is, over here, I'm
going to go ahead
and say, this is--
I'm starting with--
I'm going to vary--
I'm starting with
the first column.
So the column is fixed here, OK?
Remember, I'm going
to column by column.
So that's why this is a 0.
And then I'm going to vary
the position of the Queen
on the row, OK?
And that i varies, all right?
And then the next
thing I'm going to do
is I'm going to go
to the second column.
And I'm going to--
so that's why this is a 1.
And then I'm going to vary
the position of the Queen
on each of the
rows corresponding
to the second column, and so
on and so forth, all right?
That's it, all right?
It's brutal code, OK?
And I'll show you, I wrote
code for eight Queens.
It goes all the way
to there, right?
So that's it.
I mean, you know, you
can see it's simple code.
I'm not-- you know, sometimes
brutish means simple--
not always.
And so this no conflicts thing
is essentially something that
is calling this noConflicts()
procedure that is doing all
of the things that I just
described to you, right?
And so if I go
ahead and run this,
and run this with four Queens--
oh yikes, this always happens.
After a while, it's
going to come back.
But when I run this
with four Queens--
let me-- let's see if
this is what we want.
One more time.
Ah, sorry.
I've been fighting this system
bug ever since I installed
macOS Sierra on my laptop.
There you go.
So this gave me my two
solutions, one of which
is up there on the board.
And this is the second solution
for the four Queens problem,
all right?
So let me go back to answer
Fadi's question, right?
So the idea here--
and the way I described
this was, look,
as I go column by column,
I only put one Queen down
on this particular
column, the current column
that I'm working on.
And the way I have
this code set up,
notice that I'm
setting this to be 1,
and then I'm resetting it
down below here, the j, i, 0,
whether it's i--
whether it's this line of
code and this line of code,
they're paired together--
or this line of code
and this line of code.
These two things are
ensuring that there's exactly
one Queen on any given column.
Because I'm only
putting that Queen down.
And then I'm taking it out and
putting it in another spot,
right?
And that's how I described
this entire procedure
to you manually, right?
That's how we worked through it.
So your contention, Fadi, is
that this check is redundant,
right?
And you're right, right?
You're absolutely right.
And so if I comment
out that check,
everything works exactly--
it's a little bit faster.
But everything works
exactly the same, all right?
So there was a reason I
put the check in there.
You asked the question.
I was going to ask
you the question.
But that is a good
question, all right?
So that's kind of the
summary of four Queens.
You can clearly imagine
generalizing this
to eight Queens.
It looks even more ugly.
This is what that
looks like, OK?
And in fact, it
would look worse,
except I decided that I'd employ
the continue statement, right?
So I don't know how many of you
know of the continue statement.
But the continue
statement essentially
says, if there's an F
predicate followed by continue,
and the predicate is
true, then you immediately
start the next iteration
of the loop, OK?
So there's two
ways that you could
say, I don't want to do anything
for the rest of the loop,
right?
There's two ways
you could do this.
One is you could say--
so I have a for loop
here, dot, dot, dot.
And if I say if condition,
then you do stuff, right?
And so this do is
indented inside of the if.
Compare that with, for if
not condition, continue.
And here you would
have do stuff,
the same do stuff, all right?
Now, if this do stuff
has indentations in it,
then you're better off--
I mean, just because I have
so many indentations-- you're
better off doing
this strategy, right?
Because if do stuff goes on
and has a bunch of ifs in it,
then you at least started
at this level as opposed
to starting at this level,
which is 2D, all right?
So that's absolutely
the only reason
why I used continue over here.
Because it would look even
more ugly if I hadn't use
continue, all right?
So if we run this--
and the only other thing--
I'm going to get back to
no conflicts in a second.
But we'll go ahead and run this.
And you see that there's
92 different solutions
to the eight Queens problem
if you don't take into account
rotations and reflections, OK?
And all of those solutions
are being printed out.
And so then, the question is,
what does that mean, right?
What does that mean?
And that comes to our selection
of the data structure,
all right?
So we did this.
This was the data
structure that you picked,
which is a natural
data structure.
You can imagine
that you could do
something that is more
compact, much more compact.
And I want to show you how
you could optimize this code,
both for succinctness as
well as memory efficiency,
by picking a different
data structure, all right?
So let's exploit the fact that
each column has only one Queen
allowed, all right?
So we want to exploit the
fact that each column only
has one Queen allowed, right?
So if you think about
it, and you say,
well, I have this big thing
here, but each of the columns
has exactly one Queen, then
sure, I could use a bit,
like I did before, of
0 and 1 to specify it.
But I do know that this thing
is going to be all 0s and a 1,
followed by all 0s, or 1
followed by all 0s, et cetera,
et cetera, all right?
So it's very constrained, if
I look at that first column,
as to what the value of
that column is, right?
And so I kind of gave
it away by running this.
But what could I
do now with respect
to representing the
configuration of the board
by doing some amount of
compaction, all right?
What can I do?
Those of you, look
at the screen and--
yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: variable for a row
SRINI DEVADAS: I could just
have a single variable that
corresponds to the row number
that this particular Queen is
on, right, in that
column, right?
And that's exactly what's
going on out there, all right?
So if I just take
that, and I take--
I'll do the bottom
one, because that's
the easiest for me to see.
But the rows go 0 through 7.
So what that says is
that, on the first column,
I have a Queen up here, OK?
And then the third
one, I have a Queen.
So I have a Queen here.
And 0-- uh-oh, I messed up.
Thank you.
Whew, that would have been bad.
So 3, and then over here--
and then, what do I have?
2, right?
So 2 is over here.
I'm going to have a panic attack
if I end up getting a conflict.
Because I drew these--
I put these Queens up here.
My name will be Mud, OK?
So 5 is over here.
And then 1 is this one
over here, all right?
And 6 is out here.
And then finally,
4 is out here, OK?
All right, don't tell
me there's a conflict.
Even if there's
one, I refuse to--
I will refuse to
admit that, all right?
So that's one of the solutions
to the eight Queens problem.
And as I mentioned, there's
really 12 distinct ones.
And so it turns
out you don't need
to muck with a 2-dimensional
list, which is confusing.
And you start flipping
I's and J's, and your life
is miserable, right?
So let's just go with a
single-dimensional list, right?
Let's just say that
if I had something
like this-- and in fact,
I'm not putting a Queen down
on this second column.
This is not something we
would do in this algorithm,
but I just want to show
you a generality, right?
I'm going to take that, and
I'm going to represent this,
as you can imagine, as a
single-dimensional Python list.
And I'm just going to put--
what am I going to put down
here according to what I just
described to you?
I'm going to put 1.
And what do you think
I should put down here?
Should I put 0?
No, no, no, a 0
would be bad, right?
Because that would imply
that there's a Queen here.
I could put minus 1, right?
Minus 1 could imply that
there's no Queen on that column.
And I could start with
a board that is empty,
which is all minus 1s, right?
And then this one would be--
this is minus 1, yep.
Sorry, I wrote 1s.
Let me write this
like that, minus 1.
That's 1.
And then I would have 2
here, and then 0 there, OK?
So what's cool about this is
the overall procedure in terms
of the column by column
incremental checking,
that control flow of the
algorithm can stay the same.
I mean, if it were
four Queens, the code
would look slightly different.
Because obviously, our
board data structure
is a little bit different.
I'm going to show you the
eight Queens code in a minute.
But it's effectively the
same algorithm, right?
There's eight loops
for eight Queens.
There's four loops
for four Queens.
And a little bit of
bookkeeping with respect
to putting the Queen
on a column would
imply that I'm changing minus
1 to 0, or I'm changing 2 to 3,
or something like
that, as opposed
to doing what I did previously,
which was putting in a 1
for a particular element
in the 2-dimensional list,
and then making it a
0, and then putting a 1
in a different spot, right?
So even that gets
a little simpler,
because I'm just overwriting.
When I go 2 the 3, it means that
I'm moving this Queen from here
to there, OK?
So there's that,
which is fairly minor.
What is much more interesting is
our checkConflicts() procedure
or our noConflicts() procedure
and what that would look like,
right?
And we had a bunch of code--
some of it was redundant--
for noConflicts().
But let's look at the code for
noConflicts() in this case.
And that's it.
It's four lines of code, OK?
And this is not
redundant, right?
So if you guys can
make this code smaller,
A plus right off the bat, OK?
Well, it is a pass-fail class,
but I'll write you a letter,
OK?
So this is essentially
the code that
would take this
new data structure
and check conflicts
in an incremental way,
OK-- same thing.
You know, I'm going to add
a new Queen to the mix.
And I'm going to be
checking the conflicts
of this new Queen versus the
existing Queens, all right?
And so let's go through this.
Because I have some time,
and that's the last thing
I want to do.
So what I have here is, I'm not
going to be checking anything
about the columns, all right?
Because I know that the
number is going to--
basically, the invariant
here is there's
going to be some number here.
It it's a negative number,
there's nothing on that column.
And if there's a
positive number,
it better be between 0 and
the number of rows minus 1.
And that is going
to tell me where
the one Queen is, all right?
So I'm done with that.
But I do have to check
that there's a row--
if there's a row problem.
There could be a row
problem, all right?
So I could put a Queen up here.
And obviously, I have
to detect that, correct?
So the way I detect that is
by the highlighted code, where
I'm just going to check
to see whether there's
two numbers that are
repeated corresponding to--
well, the current-- so I know
what the value of current is.
It's not going to be
minus 1, because current
is going to be a real Queen
put into a particular position.
I mean, the last
thing you want is
to check two minus
1s for equality
and throw up a conflict.
Because I mean, that's
just empty versus empty.
You know, there's no conflict.
But board current is guaranteed,
by the invocation procedure,
to be a positive number--
I should say a
non-negative number,
either is 0 up until 7 in
our case of our eight Queens
problem.
And I just need to check
to see that that value--
let's call it 4--
doesn't exist in any of
the other columns, correct?
So that's it.
It's a little loop, but
it's three lines of code.
And in that same
loop, we're going
to be actually checking
for, it turns out,
both classes of
diagonal conflicts, OK?
In this line of code here,
can someone explain me--
explain to me what this line
of code is doing, all right?
What am I doing here?
I mean, even pictorially
would be fine.
Or you know, use your
arms and wave, right?
What is that line of code doing?
I mean, roughly, it's checking
for diagonal conflicts,
but I want more, all right?
How is it checking for
diagonal conflicts?
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I think the
difference between the index
numbers of that one we had
is that the values have
the same difference.
SRINI DEVADAS:
That's exactly right.
So if you think about
what's going on, remember,
we're talking squares here.
You know, no rectangles, right?
Maybe we could have a
homework assignment where
we have rectangular
chessboards, and do things,
and confuse everybody, right?
But the good news here is
that it's a square, right?
I like squares, OK?
And squares are
easy to deal with,
because you end
up in a situation
where you know that how much
you move in this direction
should be exactly
the same that you
move in the other
direction, all right?
That's what a diagonal
in a chessboard
is, right-- you know,
on a square board is.
You need to move in the same
amount of movement, all right?
So you're not talking
about diagonals
that look like that, right?
That's not what
you're talking about.
So what this means is-- if you
go look at this line of code,
what it says is--
my current is telling me--
for this particular column, it's
telling me what row I'm on, OK?
That's really what the value--
the value-- I'm sorry,
this is the column number.
Excuse me, I misspoke.
Current is telling me what
the column number is, OK?
And this board
current is telling me
what row number there is.
So board current gives
me the row number
for the current
column, all right?
And i is whatever column
that I'm comparing against.
I need to enumerate the
different columns that I'm
comparing against, all right?
So if I look at this
and that, you'll
find that the
difference between--
this is 1, 1--
2, 1, right?
So this column is 2,
and the row is 1, right?
So I'll just say
2 equals column,
and row equals 1 for this
thing over here, all right?
And then I'll use a
different color for this one.
Here I have, the column 3--
the column is equal to 3.
And the row equals 0, OK?
Right?
Clearly, that's a
conflict, correct?
And the reason there's a
conflict, mathematically
speaking, is because the
difference in the columns
is the same as the
difference in the rows, OK?
3 minus 2-- well 2 minus 3--
2 happens to be greater than--
sorry, 2 happens
to be less than 3.
3 happens to be greater than 2.
But the absolute value
of the difference
is something that you
need to take into account.
Because you could have diagonals
in both directions, right?
So that ABS-- the
absolute value over there
is key, because it
tells you that it's
checking for both this diagonal
as well as this diagonal,
right?
And so that's it.
So if you think about
this being a square,
and you go look at the
comparisons between the values
on the rows, and if that
value, the difference,
is the same, in absolute
terms, as the difference
in the columns, you
have a conflict.
Otherwise, you don't
have a conflict, right?
Because then you're going off.
The diagonal is going
away, through the board,
but a Queen is not
on it, all right?
So I guess I did run it,
so I won't run it again.
But I'll leave you
with the thought--
and we'll talk about
this next time--
is how in heck can we make this
code look prettier, all right?
And we will go and at a--
from here on out, we'll be
looking at a programming
paradigm that's very powerful.
I won't give it away.
You probably know what it is.
But we'll talk about it
first thing tomorrow.
And one of the
things we will do,
we'll do a different
puzzle tomorrow as well.
But we'll take a look at
the eight Queens code,
make it prettier,
and also get it
to the point where it solves
the n Queen's problem where n is
an input to do the procedure.
The problem with this code is
it only solves eight Queens.
I showed you code
for four Queens
that only solved four Queens.
If I told you that I needed
you to write code that
solves n Queens where n is
an argument to the procedure,
you wouldn't be able to do that
with this iterative strategy
unless you bounded and wrote
n different pieces of code,
right, one of which
has four loops,
and the other one
has five loops,
and the other one has six loops.
And you would still need
to know what n is, OK?
All right, so see you next time.